This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A few months before the end of the world, Paul Monaco posted this message on YouTube. Hello, everyone. Paul Monaco here. Buddha Paul is most of you. Know me as...um...you probably all heard the news, Yeiland. The Sims Online, closing down. The world that was ending was called The Sims Online. It was an online version of one of the most popular computer games ever made. You've all been wonderful. You've helped me through a hard time in my life when I first got online.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在世界末日来临前的几个月，保罗·摩纳哥在YouTube上发布了这条消息。大家好，我是保罗·摩纳哥。佛系保罗就是你们大多数人认识我的样子……嗯……你们可能都听说了这个消息，EA Land，《模拟人生在线》要关闭了。这个即将终结的世界叫做《模拟人生在线》。它是史上最受欢迎的电脑游戏之一的在线版本。你们大家都太棒了。当我刚开始上网时，你们陪我度过了人生中一段艰难的时光。
But ironically, the online version of The Sims was not very popular. They ended up losing tons of subscribers and changing the name to EA Land, and then they finally pulled the plug. As you can probably hear, EA Land is not a normal video game. There are no monsters, no killing, and although it had some competitive elements, for many players competition wasn't the point at all. Unlike a lot of other games where you might be shooting people or slaying dragons or something, this is a game about socializing.
但讽刺的是，《模拟人生》的在线版本并不怎么受欢迎。他们最终流失了大量订阅用户，并将名字改为EA Land，最后彻底关停了服务器。正如你可能听到的那样，EA Land不是一款普通的游戏。这里没有怪物，没有杀戮，虽然它有一些竞争元素，但对许多玩家来说，竞争根本不是重点。不像许多其他游戏，你可能在射击别人或屠龙什么的，这是一款关于社交的游戏。
That's Robert Ashley. And Robert Ashley? He produces a very popular and fantastic internet radio show that's been on a very long hiatus. And the creator of a life well wasted. A life well wasted. It's about video games and the people who love them. And EA Land was a video game that had dedicated few absolutely loved.
那是罗伯特·阿什利。罗伯特·阿什利是谁？他制作了一个非常受欢迎且精彩的互联网广播节目，该节目已经停播了很长一段时间。他也是《A Life Well Wasted》的创作者。《A Life Well Wasted》是关于电子游戏以及热爱它们的人们的节目。而EA Land是一款被少数忠实玩家绝对热爱的电子游戏。
The crowd that had attracted, I think, were people who just wanted to get together and sort of chat, meet strangers. It was a nice place. Over time it became a kind of intimate, almost bar, like the cheers of video games. Where everyone knows your name and at the moment that Paul Monaco aka Buddha Paul found EA Land, it was exactly what he needed most. land, it was exactly what he needed most. My wife had a long-term illness. She from a blood transfusion she had hepatitis C. And the last three years or so of her life were pretty, you know, pretty much a challenge for both of us.
我认为它吸引的人群只是那些想聚在一起聊天、结识陌生人的人。那是一个不错的地方。随着时间的推移，它变成了一种亲密的、几乎像酒吧一样的地方，就像电子游戏界的《干杯酒吧》。在那里每个人都知道你的名字。在保罗·摩纳哥（又名佛系保罗）发现EA Land的那一刻，这正是他最需要的东西。我的妻子患有长期疾病。她因为一次输血感染了丙型肝炎。她生命中最后三年左右的时间，对我们俩来说都是相当大的挑战。
And after she passed away, I had absolutely no function of then the wake up go to work and go to sleep again. With with her illness, I didn't get out of socialized much. We were able to go out to the bars and meet up with friends and have dinner. I totally be socialized myself. And this game was kind of a way for me to just kind of get back into into living again. It was it was pretty amazing.
在她去世后，我完全失去了生活动力，除了起床、上班、睡觉，什么也做不了。因为她的病，我没有太多社交。我们以前能出去逛酒吧、见朋友、吃晚餐。我完全与社会脱节了。而这款游戏对我来说是一种让我重新开始生活的方式。这真的很神奇。
In Paul began to live for E.A.L.A.L.D. He would play it for hours and hours. It was the first thing he did when he got home from work. You treated to a big warm greeting everyone would say hi and you know your I.M.S. would be beeping along and you'd be in and taking it with that. It made you feel really good. your IMS would be beeping along and you'd be hitting it with that. It made you feel really good. It wasn't the real world, but his friends were real friends. In virtual worlds, do have an upside. You're a race, you're a college religion,
保罗开始为EA Land而活。他会一连玩上好几个小时。这是他下班回家后做的第一件事。你会受到热情的问候，每个人都会说你好，你知道你的即时通讯软件会一直响个不停，你会沉浸在其中。这让你感觉非常好。虽然这不是现实世界，但他的朋友们是真实的朋友。在虚拟世界里，确实有其优势。你的种族、你的大学、宗教，
all that can be totally masked and you're truly judged on who you really are and how you present yourself. There's no prejudice, there's no preconceived anything. You're really taking a face value. People could really like break loose and and be themselves and have some fun. It just feels really good. But Paul's utopia didn't last because E.A.L.A. and started hemorrhaging money. The writing was on the wall, the surbra was about to go dark, and this event, this virtual apocalypse, might only exist in the memory of the players if it weren't for Dr. Henry Lowwood.
所有这些都可以被完全掩盖，你真正被评判的是你真实的样子以及你如何展现自己。没有偏见，没有先入为主的观念。你真的是以真实面目示人。人们可以真正地释放自我，做回自己，享受乐趣。这感觉真的很好。但保罗的乌托邦并没有持续下去，因为EA Land开始入不敷出。大势已去，服务器即将变黑，如果不是亨利·洛伍德博士，这个虚拟的末日事件可能只会存在于玩家的记忆中。
I had just stumbled across this project by Henry Lowwood. My name is Henry Lowwood, who is this archival researcher at Stanford. And I had a project called How They Got Game, which is on the history of digital games and simulations, saving video games for future generation. You know, 50, 100, 200 years from now, how are we gonna save that history? You know, like we've gotta save the video games.
我偶然发现了亨利·洛伍德的这个项目。我叫亨利·洛伍德，是斯坦福大学的一名档案研究员。我有一个名为“他们是如何获得游戏的”项目，该项目研究数字游戏和模拟的历史，旨在为后代保存电子游戏。你知道，50年、100年、200年后，我们将如何保存那段历史？你知道，我们必须保存这些电子游戏。
So Dr. Lowood and his colleagues preserve what happens inside video games. Now for a single player game like Pac-Man, for example, this is easy. You effectively take out the Atari cartridge and put it on the shelf. But saving multiplayer on-line games is not so simple. Saving the software alone is kind of a barren exercise. If you save the code for Eiland and turn it on 100 years from now, you'd enter a world and nothing
所以洛伍德博士和他的同事们保存了电子游戏内部发生的事情。对于像《吃豆人》这样的单机游戏，这很容易。你只需取出雅达利卡带并把它放在架子上即可。但保存多人在线游戏就没那么简单了。仅仅保存软件是一种毫无意义的行为。如果你保存了EA Land的代码并在100年后启动它，你进入的世界里什么都没有，
would be there. All the things that Paul Monaco and his friends love would be impossible to find. You need to document what people are doing in these spaces. That situation is much more like what a historian or an archivist would do when faced with the problem of documenting the real world. So when Dr. Lowood caught wind of E A-Land shutting down, he had the opportunity to record something a historian or archaeologist would die to witness firsthand in the real world. To see what it would be like when an online world came to an end.
保罗·摩纳哥和他的朋友们所热爱的一切都将无处可寻。你需要记录人们在这些空间里所做的事情。这种情况更像是一位历史学家或档案管理员在面对记录现实世界的问题时所做的事情。因此，当洛伍德博士得知EA Land即将关闭时，他有机会记录下历史学家或考古学家在现实世界中梦寐以求亲眼见证的事情。看看当一个在线世界终结时会是什么样子。
What happens when a virtual world closes? The end of a cunter. What is it like to be there in the last minute and when it shuts down? So the tape is rolling in the last few hours via land or being recorded and the most dedicated diehard users are there exchanging virtual hugs and reminiscing. The players are typing messages that appear like comic book word bubbles. You hear all these avatars cry. And you also hear all the coos and moans in the gibberish language of the game known as Simlish. And you know, they sound like they're gonna be bombed and everything, but it's not like a big pity party.
当一个虚拟世界关闭时会发生什么？一个时代的终结。在最后一分钟以及它关闭时身处其中是什么感觉？所以录音带在EA Land的最后几个小时里一直在转动，最忠实的死忠用户在那里交换虚拟拥抱并回忆往事。玩家们打出的信息像漫画书里的对话气泡一样出现。你听到所有这些化身在哭泣。你还能听到游戏中被称为“模拟语”的胡言乱语中的咕哝声和呻吟声。你知道，他们听起来好像要崩溃了，但这并不是一场大型的悲情派对。
But then toward the end of the night, there's this radio station that you can listen to in the game called Charmed Radio. And they had this DJ there named Spike. He is sort of the only voice that you end up hearing at the end of the world. In his soon as he starts talking, you understand what is being lost. Hey guys, the last time you're going to have me speak, well, the last time before TESL goes down. I just want to thank you all. It's been an amazing experience. It really has and I'd probably saw my myself cry but I can't. I can't stress enough how much you guys have been to me over the past however many years it's been. It really has
但在深夜临近结束时，游戏里有一个你可以收听的广播电台，叫做“魅力电台”。他们那里有一位名叫斯派克的DJ。他算是你在世界末日时唯一能听到的声音。他一开口，你就明白正在失去什么。嘿，伙计们，这是你们最后一次听我说话了，嗯，在EA Land关闭之前。我只想感谢你们所有人。这是一次奇妙的经历。真的，我可能想哭，但我不能。我无法用言语表达你们在过去这些年里对我有多重要。这真的
been awesome. Some people don't get attached to things, but when you make friends, I look people having this game. It's actually really hard. So, I'm going to play the last song. It's Sarah Brightman and Andrea Bichelli. Time to say goodbye. Hopefully you guys will like, it's been such my Yahoo ID is 1,2,3,4,5,
太棒了。有些人不会对事物产生依恋，但当你在这款游戏中结交朋友时，这真的很难。所以，我要播放最后一首歌。是莎拉·布莱曼和安德烈·波切利的《告别时刻》。希望你们会喜欢，我的雅虎ID是12345，
D- D- Are you why? 1,2,3,4,5. You're lucky in life, everybody. And the best wishes. I'll have you all and that's been great knowing you. Take care guys, and
D-D-Are you why? 12345。祝你们生活幸运，大家。最好的祝福。我拥有你们所有人，认识你们真是太好了。保重，伙计们，还有
let's just, I just want to, even if you haven't got a drink, propose a toast to Parasad who's been absolutely amazing. Parasad, we can have done this for that. Thank you. You get this feeling like being on the deck of the Titanic. Anyone who actually stayed to the end was very much invested in the game on an emotional level. When they pulled the plug on the server, bits and pieces of the world started to disappear.
让我们，我只是想，即使你没有喝的，也为一直以来绝对棒极了的Parasad干杯。Parasad，没有你我们做不到。谢谢。你会有种身处泰坦尼克号甲板上的感觉。任何坚持到最后的人都在情感层面上对这款游戏投入了极大的感情。当他们拔掉服务器插头时，这个世界的碎片开始消失。
The environment began to disintegrate. The texture on the trees flickered, and all the people froze in blanks out of existence. The actual ending was, you know, not with a bang with a whimper. And the last thing that they saw was basically just an error message, a server disconnect message. And then the world ended. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine,
环境开始瓦解。树木上的纹理闪烁，所有人都冻结并消失在虚无中。真正的结局，你知道，不是一声巨响，而是一声呜咽。他们看到的最后一件事基本上只是一个错误信息，一个服务器断开连接的信息。然后世界就结束了。《99%隐形》的制作团队是萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼，还有我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Arxine的办公室制作，
an architecture and interior's firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. I produced this story a long time ago for a radio show called Snap Judgment. Also from Oakland, California, I was their first senior producer many many years ago. In of all the people and places I worked for in radio, it is the credit for which end of the video. at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司。很久以前，我为一档名为《Snap Judgment》的广播节目制作了这个故事。同样来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰，多年前我曾是他们的第一位高级制作人。在我为之工作过的所有广播电台和地方中，这是视频结尾的制作人员名单。在99pi.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。